are we
live we are live uh good evening uh
members good evening and welcome to this
uh Northwest planning committee held on
the 8th of November 2023 my name is
councelor Mark darham I'm chairperson of
this committee members we're streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
by being present in this meeting you're
giving your consent to be recorded
during each
item uh please put your hand up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
can I ask members to avoid approaching
the top table and you're not going to do
that anyway ass this could create
interference um please note that YouTube
live stream sound recording is dependent
on the correct use of the microphones
therefore can ask when invited to speak
you remembers to turn on your microphone
and turn it off when finished please
reference a page or paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers keep
your contributions as clear and concise
as possible uh item to his apologies for
absence uh do we have any apologies for
absence please yes uh coun whiffin
because she's um had to care for
somebody tonight so she's able to
um coun H for domes okay so we have
apologies from Council wiffin and Hughes
this
evening um item three is minutes it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 13th of September to
be found on pages 7 to
12 are approved as a true and accurate
record I so move are you seconding
councelor Morgan or have you I'm not
actually I'm just pointing out that I I
stand to be corrected but I think my um
my proposal to refuse the application on
the church road development was seced by
councelor
Hughes uh
okay not that necessary mix up but I
thought it ought yeah that's fine we we
can amend
accordingly okay thank you very much
indeed item four Declarations of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-reg interests related to items
of business on this agenda having a
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
you are reminded that you are also
required to disclose an interest as soon
as you become aware should the need
arise during the
meeting we have
no Declarations of Interest so we can
move straight on to agenda item
five uh which is the first report this
evening application 23 stroke treble 021
full land adjacent to East Home
latchington Road pearly and this was a
member calling by councelor white who is
taking us through this Mr Johnson uh
Lisa Greenwood okay M Greenwood you are
ready to
go if we could hear
you yeah we can't hear
Lisa are you
uh moving moving we are moving are you
muted or no she's not muted
uh
okay I can hear something very
fly obviously
nowhere I assume somebody I'm assuming
somebody's moving that cursor because
I'm not doing it with telepathic Powers
but
um it was it was fine a while ago yeah
yeah yeah yeah we did a test
earlier
okay this is upsetting my
timings
sor I know I know I've had issues with
teams and other people and signing in
out in and out of teams worked recently
so don't whether Leisa needs to do other
speakers turned on as far as we
know we can all hear each other though
yes yeah we've got you hey there we go
yep okay yeah we go go go perfect okay
this application is for the erection of
two dwellings with Associated
landscaping and anciliary work at land
Jason East Home latchington Road Perle
the site is located on the Northern side
of latchington road outside of a defined
settlement boundary and is an open
Countryside a dropped curb is located
along the southern boundary and this
provides access to the rear of the site
for maintenance to be provided to the
field to the rear this section of Laton
road is characterized by ribbon
development on both sides the
development on the Northern side closest
to the site is of a single story the
building directly to the West is a
bungalow with detached garage and to the
east is a farmhouse with Associated
buildings of palale pits
Farm the planning of history for the
site is a material consideration in 2008
Planning Commission was sought for the
erection of two Chalet Bungalows The
Proposal was refused as the development
was found to be contrary to the
development plan the development would
have a harmful and adverse effect on the
character and appearance of the rural
area to the detriment of the visual
immunity of the countryside location
furthermore the site is remote from
community services and essential support
facilities and is inaccessible
an appeal was then made against this
decision and the appeal was dismissed
the inspector concluded that housing
development at this site would have an
urbanizing influence consolidating the
Rhythm development along latchington
Road and this would have an adverse
effect on the rural character and
appearance of the surrounding area
further The Proposal was contrary to the
local plan which directs new development
Des s sits within the defined settlement
boundaries in order to create a
sustainable pattern of development
future occupiers would be highly reliant
on the use of the car to access the
facilities and services and the
inspector researched that any new
development needs in cold n could be met
within the settlement
boundary now this slide shows the
elevations proposed for the refuse
scheme and as you can see the
development proposal was of a single
story and the inspector stated that this
along with the associated residential
paraphernalia would have an urbanizing
effect on the rural
area this show slide shows the proposed
layout of the scheme we're assessing
today which without buildings to the
rear attached garages and parking at the
frontage slides these slides show the
proposed elevations for plot one the
maximum height of the dwellings proposed
is 10.8 22
M and then next
to now you have
Frozen
no
okay could be Lisa's connection I
guess she has frozen can you can you
still hear us in the chamber well I can
hear you Sean yeah yeah it must be
Lisa's
connection I can see here's East home
okay this is the site itself Lisa I'm
sorry you're going to have to rewind cuz
you froze so we didn't pick any of that
up uh you just got to the second plot
plot plot two the second plot yeah the
second plot
elevations
okay okay that's it thank
you yeah okay uh these slides show the
proposed floor
plans and and this slide shows the
proposed floor plan for the out building
to the rear as stated in the office's
report the proposed elevations for the
out buildings have not been provided
however the floor plans show that the
proposed out buildings would provide
accommodation in the form of a living
room kitchen and bathroom and would
measure 10 m by 4 M now here are some
slides um to show photographs of the
site and the adjacent residential
development this is the access which
provides access to the field to the rear
um this was approved um simply so that
the fields could be maintained for no
other
reason this is East home which is a
single story
Bungalow you can see it again there with
the site
there this is a 1 and a half story
slightly further to the
west and these are the single story
buildings to the
east as members are aware the council is
now now able to demonstrate a robust
5year housing land Supply the site is
located outside of a defined settlement
boundary the footway that links the site
to the settlement is not lit which would
deter future occupiers of the site to
access the settlement on foot during the
hours of darkness and in inclement
weather the settlement of Colt Norton is
also classified in the local development
plan as a smaller village with few or no
services and Facilities the use of the
car does not support the objectives of
local or national planning policy which
promote sustainable travel with regard
to the impact on the intrinsic character
and beauty of the open Countryside the
pattern of development found at this
section of lington road is that of
ribbon development the application site
comprises a parcel of undeveloped land
that is laid to grass with a hedro
border along the frontage open and
undeveloped plots such as this make a
positive contribution to the character
and appearance of the rural area and the
dwellings to the east and west are of a
single story and set within generous
plots Not only would the proposed
development be at odds with the pattern
of development The Proposal would create
an urbanizing effect is that is at odds
with the s's rural setting unlike the
refuse scheme however which proposed two
Bungalows this development proposes two
twostory detached dwellings that would
extend to almost 11 m in height when
viewed at the street scene the dwellings
would be visually prominent and out of
keeping the neighboring single story
development and would cause even greater
harm than the previously refuse ski in
addition a window and balcony proposed
along the first floor side elevation of
plot one would result in the overlooking
of the neighboring site East home for
the reason stated it is therefore
recommended that planning permission is
refused thank you
chair thank you very much
indeed well okay um councelor white you
called this in um I did I did I called
it in because I everybody knows I'm
generally in favor of small developments
and I wanted to be certain exactly what
the application was and exactly entail
which you don't really get until you get
to the planning meeting and um the
photos are actually quite misleading
it's it's on a a very straight fast Road
and it's um that would be set in between
it's a big field and it's set in between
two single story houses I mean you've
got the um site where we gave permission
for um converting a stable block and
then on the other side that's the sort
of um weather-boarding one the blue one
and on the other side there's there's
the cottage there and um I know I know
that there doesn't seem to be problems
with flooding but that field is about a
foot above the main road and the history
of it was that they um the the residents
bought it to stop Travelers moving on um
and they they sort of promised they were
never going to build on it but obviously
time moves on um anyway what I want to
say was I wanted to have a really
detailed look at the houses themselves
and they are completely out of keeping
so actually you'll be surprised that
after calling it to committee I actually
agree with the officer's recommendation
I quite surprised myself on that one so
um i' I'd like to propose that we accept
the officer's recommendation
seconded well yes yes it's a shame we
had to go this far but um oh so we have
a public speaker I'm sorry sorry we have
a sorry can I just we do have a speaker
the agent the agent for the applicant
okay sorry I I didn't see that so
um so
um well no we'll hear we'll hear the
agent so thank you very much before we
go on any
further thank you yeah thank you have
two minutes from when you start to speak
I'm sure you know the score can everyone
hear me yeah yes loud and clear okay and
thank you for this opportunity to
address your committee I'd like to draw
your attention to some crucial aspects
of the proposed development and its
significance within the local context
the 5year housing land Supply is a
minimum requirement not a and there's a
grind trend of develop developers
winning appeals against its use as a
reason for refusal this development also
contributes essential windfall housing
aligned with the council's housing needs
the officer's Reliance on a 2009 appeal
decision is outdated the mppf was not
published in 2009 and the need for
housing was not at the Forefront of the
planning system the value to be
attributed to the provision of
additional housing is now much higher
cold Norton which offered Liberty to
facilities at the time of appeal is now
defined as a medium Village offering
facilities meeting residents day today
needs and is nearly 0.4 miles away the
officers claim that the proposed
dwelling doesn't match the immediate
context over overlooks the local
architectural quality of surrounding
buildings the design and access
statement establishes a local precent
for this St of design despite not being
strictly within cold Norton settlement
boundary this approach is supported by
the national essics and modern design
guides aimed at raising architectural
standards I'd also like to make the
following key points regarding design
the officer concerns about the impact of
the neighbor mement can be addressed
with planning conditions examples
include obscure glazing for the bedroom
window nearest the neighbor and a
visibility screen on the balcony the
height of the proposed wedings is lower
than perceived with only the chimneys
reaching 10.8 M and the ridge line at
9.2 similar to nearby twostory buildings
opposite the assertion of non-conforming
linear development on thaton road is
questionable the majority of nearby
dwellings are set back 10 to 25 M from
the road Edge and the proposed dwellings
are set back over 20 m east home an
exception is set back 34 M the officer
even acknowledge in their report that
the proposed development would not
appear unduly overbearing due to the
separation distance and orientation
despite it height supposedly exceeding
10 meters in conclusion the development
benefits outweigh visual concerns making
it a logical addition to the area I urge
you to support this plan in application
thank you for your
time uh thank you very much indeed thank
you councelor
Thompson um thank you chairman um yes
I'm actually glad we heard that but
having paid careful attention to the
agent's letter that I believe all
members of the committee received I
don't know that I'm happy about um the
reason for refusal number three the one
about the
overlooking and I would put in an
amendment that we remove that um
otherwise I fully support the other two
and and I am in agreement with the
officer's recommendation to refuse but
if if that those matters could be
mitigated against I'd be concerned about
including those as a reason for refusal
because 10 met seems like quite
reasonable distance to me and since it's
a second window in each case then it
could be obscure glazed I would have
thought but obviously uh M that needs to
be seconded and supported by the
committee of course thank you m
Greenwood have you got a comment un
answer to councelor
Thompson and I have I the reason that we
wouldn't obscure the glazing is because
this serves a
bedroom which is a habitable room and
actually looking at that plot the bed
overlooks that window so that's the
reason that we wouldn't suggest obscure
glazing in this instance we would do
that if it was an on Suite or a bathroom
or something similar to that but not on
this
occasion and I think with regards to the
fact that it's overbearing when we're
looking at something overbearing we look
at we're looking at the impact on the
immediate neighbors um so because of the
separation distance um it wouldn't
necessarily appear as overbearing but
when you view it at the street scene and
you're looking at a development that's
nearly 11 m in height it's going to it's
going to appear um very very out of
keeping with the single story
development either side I think
councelor Thompson was refer was
councelor Thompson was referring to the
to refusal um point three were you not
oh well I was yes overlooking
overbearing overing overbearing
definitely it was the overlooking I was
less about and I thought it was a second
window in the
bedroom but um obviously I'll be guided
by the officers I I just want to be sure
we're doing this right I wouldn't want
to do anything unreasonable and um have
a problem over one reason for refusal
thanks um Miss Greenwood have you got
can you clarify that for councelor
Thompson um I think again we wouldn't
look to obscure that window um unless Mr
Johnson would would disagree um having
looked at the plans that's that's quite
a large window okay you would be looking
to obscure Mr Json is shaking his head
so I think he's yeah just I I I concur
with um Mrs Greenwood okay thank you
councelor
Sidle uh thank you chairman what the
other reason it's overbearing is there's
a balcony which people could go out and
look into next door's Garden so the
balcony in itself is is overbearing and
and would would you know it be an
intrusion and you can't obscure on a
balcony at all
so okay counselor
white thank you for allowing to come
back um yeah I mean the thing is I I
read the emails from the uh agent and I
listen to him again now and the thing is
it is completely out of context and
although they may only be however many
meters tall the fields already raised
and the street scene is Bungalows and
shallow Bungalows directly adjacent to
it and it it just does not does not fit
in with the surrounding areas so for me
it's um I can't support it I'm sorry and
I still stand by even listening to what
he says I still um Thompson can we just
have one speaking at once please thank
you councelor white yeah councelor
Morgan oh yeah thank you chairman I just
really want to comment that obviously
I've listened to the um the agent
submission um and read his email Etc uh
but um the fact that this was refused
back in 2008 and that refusal was upheld
uh on appeal I don't see anything
particular that strikes me looking
through the documentation that anything
has changed in that and that was for an
application for two smaller buildings
therefore I therefore concur with
Council White's proposal this be refused
I think the significant change is that
they're about three times the size and
even more overbearing so um so did I I
have a proposer and seconder for
proposed and councelor Morgan so that is
a proposal for the officers
recommendation to approve those in favor
please sh no refuse to refuse I'm sorry
to refuse please
indicate that's everybody so that is
refused we now move on
to agenda item six which is harmony
kennels uh Brook House Bar Lane pearly
it's the councelor white show again this
evening um uh Council another call in
from councelor White um who's taking us
through this one uh Mrs Kurt C Mrs KT
c yeah thank you good evening members
thank you chairman uh so this is an
application at Harmony uh kennels in
pearly for the erection of a proposed
single story dwelling cart Lodge and out
building
the site is situated outside of the
defined development boundary to the
north of a rudley Green Lane at the east
of Spar Lane uh perly Village is about
half a mile to the south of the site uh
and access into the site is gained from
Spar Lane which is off um chelsford
Road show you on the map here so we've
got Spar Lane here uh and um chelsford
Road here and here's rudley Green Road
so this is an aerial photograph of the
site uh we can see the buildings uh
associated with the former kenal use of
the site uh we can also see the
relationship with some of the most
immediate neighboring properties as well
um so we've got the laboring properties
here and here uh and and over here as
well and then we' got Spar Lane here and
we can see all the buildings up
here uh some members may recall that an
application for a dwelling uh and a
garage was previously considered by the
committee in February of this year the
application was approved therefore the
principle of residential development on
soci has already been agreed and
established uh so in assessing this
current application the main
considerations related to design layout
appearance and the impact on the wider
Countryside
setting uh on here we've got the block
plan of the approved scheme um and we
can see that the access was proposed off
uh spar Road um here we can see the
single story uh dwelling uh and the
garage building and the garden curtilage
uh to the side and and to the rear uh
members might be able to just make out
the faint red line here which is the uh
buildings that are proposed to be
demolished so here we have the proposed
block plan uh for the current scheme
being considered uh we can see that the
proposed dwelling in sort of a similar
similar position to that of the approved
scheme orbe it has moved 3 m South um
from the boundary which has enabled a
larger graveled uh for court here to the
front of the dwelling uh the proposed
detach garage um to the side is also in
a similar position to that the approved
scheme the current application uh
proposes to introduce an out building to
the east of the site which is here uh
officers have raised concern in the
report um regarding this in relation to
um extending built form on the site into
the
countryside so here are the elevations
of the approved scheme for the uh
dwelling we can see it's quite a modest
uh building and the materials proposed
were sort of black weather boarding and
um a red brick pth uh and the design and
appearance has similar to sort of an
agricultural or rural out building um so
it would blend in with the countryside
setting so here we've got the elevations
of of the uh proposed scheme uh we can
see it's s of a more ornate uh
appearance and design than what's been
approved it would have an overall height
of 6.4 M this is an increase of 1.5 M
from the approved
scheme uh the former kennel buildings on
site were lowrise buildings with a
height of 3.9
M um officers have raised concern that
the increase in height of the dwelling
would increase its prominence in the
wide open Countryside to set in uh we
can see there are three protruding uh
gables on the front and on the rear
elevations which in increases its
overall sort of bulky
appearance um increases overall depth as
well um the fenestration proposed has
also um changed from that of the
approved scheme um with um most
noticeably this glazed Gable uh on the
rear
elevation so this is the floor plan of
the approv approved
scheme and here we've got the floor plan
of the um current scheme that's being
considered it's not dissimilar um in
terms of the accommodation proposed um
however the the footprint um has
increased uh in size marginally we can
see see it's simple story uh with two
bedrooms um on Suite kitchen living room
uh utility room and an enlarged entrance
hall so here we've got the garage um
elevations for the garage cart Lodge um
it's of a similar S size and scale and
appearance to that previously approved
uh and officers raised no concern U with
in regards to this part of the um
proposal so these are the elevations of
the proposed um out building that have
been submitted for
consideration um the out building would
have a width of 10 m um and a depth of
8.9 M and the height is 3.9 9 to the
bridge is quite a substantial size
building um and officers have raised
concern about this in the uh report um
due to the the lack of a clear
justification for its sides um in the
last two weeks we have received revised
plans from the applicant for the
outbuilding um which we can see the
depth and the width remain the same but
the porch element has been removed um
however these just to note these plans
haven't been accepted Ed by officers um
as the committee report had already been
drafted when they were received and they
don't overcome um officer concerns
regarding the uh the
size so here we got the uh floor plan
for the out building um it refers to a
uh gymnasium area here and separate
rooms for a garden storage um a bathroom
and and a store uh the design and access
statement refers to a hydrotherapy unit
uh being provided however this isn't
shown on the uh floor plans uh
submitted uh and these are the floor
plans revised Flor plan that came in
within the last um couple of weeks um
and it's the same um albeit that the
port area has now been um
removed just looking at some photographs
of the site um this is chelsford road
you can just about make out the um the
existing buildings in between the um
property here and this is um some photos
of what the um existing buildings look
like at the moment um on the
site so in um summary uh the officer
recommendation is is refusal um there is
concern that the proposal as a result of
its design layout and appearance would
result in a prominent form of
development and visual intrusion and
encroachment into the rural landscape
setting it would also be distinctly at
odds with the unassuming presence of the
existing building on site and that of
the approved scheme um and the offic of
recommendation for is always set out on
page 47 of the committee report thank
you thank you very much indeed we have
no speakers I don't think have we no
speakers no speakers that's great
councelor white your call in thank you
Mr chairman yeah I actually called this
one in um because I have some concerns
great concerns about the recommendation
for refusal because it was only in
February we as the officer said approved
the principle of a bungalow on site and
yes they've raised the ridge height by
about 4 feet um but if you look at the
um photos um the first photo that we had
from the main road it's a wacking great
twostory house and this sits behind that
house so you're you're really not going
to see anything um from the road at all
and in fact this one we recommended for
refusal at Northwest planning was
refusal and we agreed with the refusal
because I had concerns it's on a tight
Bend and that access is off that tight
Bend and I didn't think that was a
suitable site for housing because the
bend however the the other members
agreed we refused it but that got
approved at appeal so we've we've lost
quite a few appeals on this site um we
have permission for a house already um I
do know the applicant um not very well
but I do know him um I've met him at the
parish Council meetings and I know he's
quite frail and quite elderly so I
haven't discussed anything with him but
it makes sense he'd want a hydrotherapy
unit because I don't think he's um
overly able and for me it's 4 feet
higher yes it's a bit ornate you can't
see anything from the road you're not
going to see it from the road so
although they've added in an extra out
building I I think the reasons for
refusal are weak and I think that
there's a good chance that we'd lose on
appeal so I think we should recommend
this for approval I don't know if I'll
get a second or not but that's my
recommendation anyway thank
you I I'll go open it up to other
officers other members I I have my
doubts and I remember this coming
forward and and being discussing I doubt
we would have approved this particular
design the first time round because what
we agreed and I recall it because it was
exactly in keeping um as a sort of
low-level weatherboarded house but
councelor sidle
thank you chair uh yeah what we approved
last time was something which sort of
matched the existing buildings that are
there was lowkey it's not next to the
road however it is right next to a
public footpath and next to a bridal way
and behind that are open field and it
would have a huge impact in the on the
countryside and would be would actually
create more urbanization in terms of
that site especially with the new out
building which is right next to the
perimeter right next to the Hedge and
right next to those fields and anybody
who's going down that path and goes up
Spar Hill and you would go up Spar Hill
which is just at the end there and you
would see all of that and it would have
a a big detrimental effect in terms of
its height and in terms of its scale and
it's nothing like we approve and so
therefore I think we should take
officers
recommendations thank you councelor
Thompson um thank you I'm going to
largely Echo councelor Sidle um
important fact I didn't support it last
time around that's immaterial because of
decisions a decision by The Authority um
but I think this
is much less pleasing I'll try and be
charitable and um yeah no I'm totally
with the officer's recommendation thank
you uh councelor moley first then
councelor yeah I concur with councelor
Sid I think it is the scale um of of the
project I think is the main concern it
does seem a bit out of with the original
proposed building councelor
Stevens thank you yes I agree with all
of that and also to say that if we were
to approve this the next thing there'll
be another small lowkey out building or
some small building in that place where
somebody will be coming forward and
asking for another one of these and the
next thing we know we'll have 10 of
these ones on on that area instead of
what we have now I think we'd be setting
a bad dangerous precedent thank you okay
so um there wasn't a second for
councelor
White's um proposal to approve this have
we got one I I'll second Council what to
approve yeah to approve the planning
permission okay thank you so that was
therefore the first proposal so we'll
put that first proposal to the vote
those in favor of councelor White's
proposal seconded by councelor Morgan
to not follow the officer's
recommendation but to approve this
application please
show two those
against four so that is
lost so I'm now looking for a proposal
thank you councelor Sidle and seconded
by councelor Stevens that is a proposal
uh to comply with the officer's
recommendations of refusal those in
favor please
show that's four those
against two that is carried so that
application is refused we now come to
agenda item seven land at Broad Street
Green Green Road Langford road and
mapole road great totam
Essex uh which is uh permanent diversion
of a public right of
way um who is taking this is Mr Johnson
I think AR
yes well done thank you from the offic
report
okay thank you
chairman this application has been made
under Section 257 of the Town and
Country planning act which relates to
foot paath affected by
development for a footpath diversion
order section 257 provides a competent
Authority MDC in this case with the
power to to authorize a diversion of any
footpath if they are satisfied that it
is necessary to do so in order to enable
development to be carried out in
accordance with the planning
permission whilst MDC is a determining
Authority Essex County Council in their
role as a highway Authority has been
instructed to process the
application and that effectively sets a
context that this is a footpath within
the middle of the haybridge development
and
and as members would have read uh
through the papers um its purpose is to
help facilitate the uh uh uh uh sod
system um through the
development um but at the same time uh
although although there is a minor
diversion of the foot path um in essence
the the the foot path uninhibited and
retaining uh uh its current status um
will be retained on the site through the
through this
diversion that's the effectively the
long and short of this proposal and I
think I'll just go to the
plans
and we can see from this one here if I
can just try and make it slightly
larger the if I just go back to the
development description because the
development description and hopefully it
has been fairly clear um what this is
about and what is to be retained so it
when it mentions um the permanent
diversion order of the sections noted A
to B and F to G and these are the roots
to be
closed
so further down here we've got
a and then we've got a a to
B and then we've got F to G so these are
the particular Parts there you can see
where it's sort of Kinks there and and
and Kinks there and also this element
that goes out here which runs alongside
the attenuation basins as part of the um
strategic
infrastructure elements of The Proposal
that have been approved
previously and just to be clear from
this point here this is a spine road
that effectively runs through the h
development to which you will have um
the local infrastructure you'll have the
schools you'll have the shops around
this area here and this point below here
is is actually um prow 17 um so that is
to be unaffected and although it it is
mentioned in the in in
the in the um location well in The
Proposal address there is no impact on
prow 17 um that is also set out clearly
with within the officer's report so on
this basis um the report recommends
approval um that and that um members um
support this application for the uh
permanent diversion of the foot path
thank you
chairman okay thank you very much so can
you just move that down a bit so in in
actual fact the change is only really at
the top there it still runs alongside
hybridge wood run similar path along
here and then and then so it's just
going to divert around that attenuation
Pond
yeah some minor there
okay okay councelor Stevens you have a
question thank you yes I do really um it
feels like we don't have a choice here
and I'd like to understand well what
would happen if we said no um is my
first well that's the question and then
the point that I wanted to raise on top
of that is the bit C to D now seems to
Route the path alongside the road I
would have thought for a pedestrian it
would be a lot more pleasant to be the
other side where the path where the path
runs at the moment and I can't see the
need to move it um maybe that could be
explained please thank
you
um well I would have to just read from
the report but I can say that the
explanation for this is set out at 3.6
of of the report um I mean I can go
through it if it just helps to make it
any more
clearer um but it sets the Contex in
terms of the green infrastructure
parameter plan and all these various
plans have have been approved a key
component is a retention and widening of
existing ditches that run alongside
existing field boundaries and for both
the transfer and storage of surface
water then it goes into more detail
there's an existing so there is a there
is there is a logical reason why it is
particular in in the places where they
where they propos
them could come back on that yes I I
mean I've read 3.6 and then read it
again because I got to the end of it and
just thought not quite sure what I
learned from all of that I'm not getting
from it why does it need to move and if
I was walking through there I'd rather
just walk in a straight line than round
I'm not quite clear how far that is but
it would just be less Pleasant to walk
next to the road than it would be to to
walk between the wood and the pond I
just I can't understand maybe I'm
missing something but I can't see the
need for it thank
you I think 3.7 said it's evident that
the diversion of Right Way 19 is
required to allow completion of the
surface water drainage infrastructure
for The Wider development so it looked
like the existing footpath is going to
be interfered with and become part of
the SS uh s scheme councelor Thompson
and then councelor Sid um thank you I
was in fact going to ask through you Mr
Johnson if that's a technical way of
saying it's going to be underwater a lot
of the time because it's going to be
through the suds yeah that would that be
about right yes that's that's
effectively the case yeah so we are
expecting um Ramblers to walk on water
at certain times of the year which I'm
sure they think they can um sorry I
counselor SLE yeah from what I
understand and from what you can make
out on the map instead of the big being
a path there there'll be a ditch there
um and and the blue there's a blue line
that goes down where the existing path
is so that's where the water's going to
flow so therefore the path can't exist
anymore okay councelor
Morgan yeah thank you Mr chairman I
think also quite look at 3.9.1 the
Ramblers Association who in my day job
have caused me considerable difficulty
in the past uh will not oppose the
proposed aversion providing those Fest
conditions is quite signif ific so I
would therefore propose that we accept
the officer's
recommendation I know exactly where
you're coming from councelor Morgan the
rambling
Association really object to anything
getting moved by an inch let alone
around a feature so I think if that if
they are happy with it coun I'll so
that's a proposal so we got a proposed
uh to agree by councelor Morgan secondy
by councelor Thompson those in favor
please
show anybody
against one okay so that is agreed thank
you very much
indeed uh that I think members
is the last of the
day uh which
means uh any items of business that the
chairperson decides are Urgent you'll be
very glad to hear there is none so I
close the meeting at
8813 thank you for your contributions
the meeting is now closed please leave
promptly